[Musica]
salve come cosa sto facendo
ma ovviamente la demonizzazione mi ha
portato cercare un altro lavoro
un vero lavoro faccio l'arbitro di
incontri di boxe adesso no no questa è
una nuova puntata di beviamoci su nel
senso che a sto giro sono io il barista
ed altri a raccontare le loro storie
non penserete che io sia l'unico ad
avere dei fan particolari non avete idea
non è vero signor merino quindi era al
cinema con la mia ragazza è già quando
ho detto che anche te le sorti del nome
senza formale o niente e pensavo contro
deve succedere sarebbe finita la è
accaduto che alla voce questa storia
perché si deve solo successi di più
strane ma questo è singolare anche
perché le altre le ho prese aprile
questa quello questa volta
facciamoci un film sulla somma sono
tornati a casa
apro la casella di posta è arrivato un
minuto prima
quindi questa persona alla mano perché
sito ac non lo sono stata ma non è
sicuramente anche quando il tempo i
ritorna lo stesso di sé tra la casa ma
quando questo pestaggio abbia mandato da
foto la silhouette delle tv e sul web
dietro c'è di mettere le ragazze ci
stiamo guardando il film al cinema ha
fatto la foto di quando da questa volta
marco non potevo solo darsi perché
vivere
quindi ecco di questa foto di teta da
dietro nero quella che persona sia la
tua ragazza è lo schermo davanti bianchi
tutto va beh almeno la foto l'ha fatta
voglio dire ci sono tanti appassionati
poi che ti conoscono molto meglio della
tua stessa famiglia e sanno molto meglio
di loro quali sono le tue vere passioni
vero signor fra hus per quanto riguarda
ragazzi che seguono parliamo di
videogiochi per me che sono una persona
molto timida sono capitate tantissime
situazioni su mezzi pubblici o comunque
luoghi dove non puoi fare rumore di
situazioni rumorosissime e parecchio
imbarazzanti ma alla fine ti fanno
piacere ma gli incontri più bizzarri
sono magari agli eventi o nei luoghi di
incontro dove magari qualcuno viene da
me dice ehi senti io ti seguo ma ti ho
conosciuto per il canale delle armi o
altre persone che dicono senti io non
seguo i videogiochi però visti i tuoi
video sulle armi è sono principalmente
appartenenti alle forze dell'ordine
persone che fanno tiro dinamico e poi ci
sono anche guardie giurate e persone che
hanno il porto d'armi a difesa personale
per questi ultimi si creano le
situazioni più divertenti perché si
parla dell'argomento
poi ad un certo punto
si arriva a parlare dell'arma utilizzata
in servizio o che sia addosso e li puoi
parte la domanda mi ama ce l'ha con te
l'arma lui fa se la vuoi vedere si
ragazzi arrivo subito e lì si va o
all'interno della macchina della persona
si va in un bagno si va in un luogo più
appartato e tranquillo si tira fuori
l'arma senza analizzare qualcuno magari
lanche smontata mi fa vedere magari
munizioni particolari che ha acquistato
che magari si possono non si possono
utilizzare determinati contesti e queste
sono diciamo le situazioni più surreali
ma anche divertenti mi siano capitate
con l'utenza che mi segue quanto è vero
c'è veramente un sacco di gente che
adorerebbe guardare la canna della mia
pistola
se capite cos'è il peggio sto parlando
del mio pene la passione che alcuni di
voi hanno va oltre il mero essere fan
c'è quell'invisibile linea di
demarcazione dettata dal proprio schermo
del computer che divide il fan dal
pubblico vero signor sa ma cu a me
capita spessissimo davvero di ricevere
meravigliose esternazioni d'affetto
rispetto e stima uniche però non posso
negare che capitino effettivamente 20 su
chi vien voglia di berci suo comunque
rifletterci un po 1 stranezze
dolcissime viene ed emozione ma
stranezze a una delle mie prime fiere un
ragazzo mi avvicino molto investito
molto serio e medie di dei consigli
fortis molto molto rigidi sul mio lavoro
mi disse di fare certe cose di non fare
altre cose e quindi guardandomi negli
occhi mi disse ti ho fatto un dono
estremamente importante
tienilo sempre con te non perderlo è
cruciale
davvero era molto serio e mi dite questa
scatola e io aprì con estrema emulsione
interesse anche perché comunque lo
prendevo molto sul serio
indipendentemente da chi tu sia meriti
tutta l'attenzione del mondo
dentro c'era una pallina di quelle
fosforescenti rimbalzine con un occhio
disegnato sopra e trovo ancora qui la
uso come honda energetica per un'action
figure di goku ma ho il terrore che sia
una sorta di device di controllo
qualcosa del genere scherzandoci sopra
perché è stato molto strano vedere
quella pallina e vedere la serietà con
cui ma la data
certo ma soprattutto sotto natale per
quanto riguarda i regali
basta il pensiero anche se quel pensiero
potrebbe essere una macumba africana
però è numericamente più fame e più
situazioni del genere ti ritrovi
soprattutto se le ai milioni di fan vero
signor fa vj un anno un annetto fa mi
siedo
al tavolo di un ristorante inizia a
mangiare e trovo sul tavolo un giornale
leggo il giornale leggo un articolo in
particolare che attira la mia attenzione
due ragazze di 14 e 15 anni più o meno
scappano dal centro italia e vengono
ritrovate al nord dopo un giorno nel mio
paesino dove abitavo io prima e la scusa
di queste ragazze dopo che l'hanno
ritrovata è stata siamo scappate per
andare ad incontrare una persona che
abbiamo conosciuto online
io che so che in quel paesino ci abitano
veramente tre persone in croce ci
abitavo io e due vecchi sapevo la realtà
dei fatti mentre leggeva il giornale ero
così chiudo il giornale lo metto via
e ho mangiato il resto del cibo con
molto sforzo e basta e santi dio e che e
ci sono varie tipologie di pubblico in
base alla tipologia del tuo canale
c'è chi al pubblico giovane c'è chi al
pubblico misto poi c'è chi anche al
pubblico adulto vero signor shy di
breaking italy visto quello che faccio
su youtube o un pubblico un po più
adulto di quello che è normalmente si
pensa siano le persone che seguono
youtube quindi venticinquenni trentenni
avevo strettamente di confini mi capita
spesso coppia passeggino bambino dentro
è molto bello perché ti seguo da tanti
anni prima al liceo e l'università ora
ho un figlio è fantastico questo caso è
simile coppia bambino alto così mi vedo
uscire lombar impazziscono perché non
sono aspettano che di qua o sei tu grida
non ci posso credere sapevo che di aver
incontrato con un pensavo oggi un casino
stanno di fatto ignorando il loro figlio
quindi io premete dalla loro agio in sa
parlare con lui
il chino sulle ginocchia prima trono
sulla spalla di dico bel bottino come ti
chiami marco conti amia e marco così è
per esempio con le dita io vado alla
madre che sorride qui inizia a fare
domande dove va e va in giro con la
mamma ma che belle scarpe eccetera
sicché bambino che un bambino non si sa
noi essere va e scappa del rom bar di
corsa e mi spaventano quindi mi alzerò
gli che ci parlava un'ora e vedo che
genitori però non seguono e mi dicono eh
io ho visto il tuo video nel quale
parlavi di non so che del referendum del
referendum e mi chiedono cose io dico
loro sì possiamo parlare del referendum
possiamo parlare interessante prostro
figlio è appena entrato al bar è che
fate lasciatemi io dico un po scherzando
ma sono preoccupato
la madre mi guarda mi sorride e dice che
non è con te non è mica nostro figlio
bello ma come non è vostro figlio sono
un ora che sto molestando un bambino in
mezzo alla strada vi vedono tutti c'è
pure la vetrata la serata entro il padre
ditemi qual con onde temi parlami del
referendum
ditemelo dopo ditemi quello che questo
figlio questo bambino non è
il tuo figlio è invece invece non mi
hanno detto niente quindi semi
incontrate c'è un bambino vicino vite vi
subito non è il nostro figlio perché non
ho intenzione di molestare dei bambini
ok sarà vantano youtube
non so mi volesse player però ok dunque
allora io ormai l'ha raccontata io non
so cosa dirvi ringrazio i partecipanti
che hanno voluto entrare nel mio bar e
io spero di fare altri open bar in
futuro spero di non di non sentire più
ragazzi buon natale noi ci ci rivedremo
sicuramente adesso tiro giù la serranda
e wow wow wow